hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
movie called the hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy there is a young man named
arthur dent one thursday morning when he
wakes up the objects around him are
vibrating by itself
turns out that this is caused by
construction workers who want to
demolish his house to become a highway
arthur who doesn't accept his house
being demolished tries to stop the
workers by lying down in front of them
not long after his friend ford comes to
his house
he then tells ford that his house would
soon be demolished by construction
workers
ford says that there is something more
important than arthur's house that is
about to be demolished he distributes
all the beer he brought with the
construction workers
after sharing it they go to a bar nearby
there ford explains that he is not from
earth but he comes from a different
galaxy he says that soon the earth will
be destroyed arthur does not believe all
the words that were said by him to
convince him ford mentions a story of
their first meeting when he first came
down to earth he tries to shake hands
with the car
at that time arthur who saw this
immediately saved him and said that the
kahar was not a robot that he could get
acquainted with
therefore he is indebted to arthur for
saving him he wants to repay his
kindness by taking arthur away from the
earth because the earth is not safe
anymore
later arthur talks about his lover named
trillian they happened to meet at a
party and began to get close to each
other until one time a person named
zafud suddenly comes to the party and
says that he comes from another planet
because the time is running out ford
asks arthur to leave the bar
when they return to arthur's house it
turns out that his house is currently
being demolished
shortly after a very large strange
spaceship appears above them panic
occurs everywhere due to the actions of
these aliens when the spaceship reaches
the atmosphere ford immediately rescues
arthur by hiding in one of the
spaceships as predicted the spaceship
can destroy the earth very easily
inside ford tells arthur that they are
in one of the wagon spaceships
wagon is one of the strangest alien
races they are not evil but they are
easily triggered and like to interfere
in a business
if they are ordered by their superiors
they quickly settle a problem
wagon is identical as a space patrol cop
basically they will act if they get
orders from their superiors
meanwhile ford inserts a strange object
into arthur's ear which is useful for
translating all languages in the
universe
not long after the wagon notices the two
of them in the ship and immediately
catches them they are thrown into outer
space but luckily there is another
spaceship that allows them to join
inside
there ford is very surprised because he
meets sephora who turns out to be his
cousin
zifat is also the newly elected
president of the entire galaxy he
managed to defeat kavula who was also
running for president
not only that he has two faces that each
have a different personality arthur is
surprised when he reunites with trillian
turns out she has been taken to outer
space when she met zafad at the party
earlier in the meantime there is outer
space news when zaphod was sworn in as
the president
unexpectedly he stole a technologically
advanced spaceship
due to his theft a vice president named
questaler teams up with wagon to bring
him back
he deliberately stole the ship to find
out about the planet named magathia he
then shows the ancient records showing
that millions of years ago there was a
race that questioned and debated about
life in the entire universe
there was also a supercomputer called
deep thought that could answer all their
questions
there were two kids who looked like the
leader of magrathia coming to see it
they wanted to get answers about the
life of the universe but they were told
to wait seven and a half million years
to get those answers
long story short seven and a half
million years have passed and now these
two kids come back to face deep thought
during that time margathia has been
filled with inhabitants the event is
also greeted with enthusiasm by the
residents because the two kids asked for
a simple answer previously then deep
thought only answers 42
instantly everyone who hears this
becomes confused to know the answer it
says that the questions asked by the two
kids were difficult to understand
they only ask about life in the universe
without explaining in more detail about
their questions
the disappointing answer 42 remains a
mystery until now
after hearing the recording zafon plans
to go to magrathia to get answers about
the universe directly from deep thought
when they head to the planet they
suddenly strayed a velvet violent by
kavula arriving there zafat asks kavula
where the exact coordinates of magrithia
he wants to give the exact coordinates
with the condition that zaphod has to
bring him a special weapon from the
planet as a guarantee he immediately cut
off one of zephod's heads when they want
to leave the place the group of wagon
comes to bring the president back to his
home planet they think that arthur and
his friends have kidnapped zafad
unfortunately trillian is caught by the
wagon and taken to their planet the
others quickly figure out how to save
her by using a mini spaceship they
immediately go to the planet
soon trillian learns a shocking fact
from the wagon that the earth has been
destroyed by them on the orders from the
president none other than zafad himself
she doesn't expect that zephod has the
desire to destroy the earth being
accused of stealing the president she
will be executed by drowning her alive
on the other hand they order a robot
named marvin to return to the spaceship
while the others will save trillion they
begin to enter and make a release form
for someone named trillian on orders
from the president
with the form given the wagon
immediately releases her he and the
questioner finally realized that
trillian and her friends are good people
they didn't intend to kidnap zaphod but
there was only a misunderstanding
between them all
after getting out of prison trillion is
angry with zapad because he has
destroyed the earth then they
immediately leave the place
in order to be able to monitor zafad's
activities questler and vagan decide to
go after them
in the end they all arrive on magathia
ford zafad and trillian manage to enter
the portal to deep thought while arthur
and marvin fail to enter it therefore
they can only wait at that place
after they wait for a long time suddenly
a man named slar approaches them
he is an expert in making a planet he
then invites arthur to see the project
he's made
at the same time the others get to deep
thought and ask about the universe but
unluckily it gives no answer at all
because they don't get the answer they
just look for the weapon kavula has
ordered before
it is a weapon that has been specially
designed to make whoever is shot say
something or feel something painful
as they get the weapon trillion
purposely fires the gun at zafad to find
out the reason why he destroyed the
earth
it turns out that the destruction of the
earth was due to a misunderstanding
between himself and wagon he says not to
worry as he has prepared a second
version of earth which will be ready
soon then they teleport to somewhere
else back to arthur and slar they are
traveling by train to ceslar's project
he explains that he is making a second
version of earth and the new version of
earth will be finished soon then they
tour the earth where they see space
workers working to fill the oceans make
mountains and more slaugh also builds
arthur's new house
when he enters his house his friends are
already inside and they are eating
while they are talking suddenly
questioner and the wagons arrive outside
arthur's house and open fire
the group immediately takes shelter in a
caravan but unfortunately marvin is hit
in the head shortly after marvin wakes
up again and takes out the weapon he has
obtained in magathia with that shot the
group of wagon immediately collapses
they are taken back to their planet
using a spaceship while zaphod reunites
with questler in the end they decide to
go to a restaurant at the end of the
universe while slar and the other
workers will complete the new version of
earth they do not forget to add plants
animals and humans like the earth in
general
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching